[Music]
okay everybody I am so so excited today
because I am joined by Zuri Reed and
Lyndon Smith who's star in National
Treasure edge of history on Disney plus
now how you guys doing today doing
awesome we're so happy to just be able
to talk about that finally right this
has been a great day yeah and I think
everyone's so excited to finally watch
it too and watch you guys absolutely
kill it in this show and one of the
things I love about it uh for you Zuri
is Tasha and Jess's relationship in the
show is great back and forth together it
seems like you guys are best friends in
real life so what is the process like
for you with Lisette to get to that
place on screen oh my gosh you know it
was so organic
um from our very first let's set and I
met over Zoom first like for for the
chemistry reads uh and it was like as if
we have known each other forever truly
we didn't have to work too hard for the
chemistry I think like we're just a
great pair and we work fabulously um
together and I'm so happy that it
resonates um on the screen yeah for sure
it really does and it's cool to hear
that it was kind of just clicked right
away and Lyndon what I also love is it's
interesting I was doing research for
this seeing that you were also on a
police drama of public morals did that
help prepare it all for being an FBI
agent in this show that is such a fun
question
um so I I did I wasn't on the law side
in public morals um but you know that
show was very much a cat and mouse game
which was similar to what we're doing
here
um and this time I get to do some
chasing
um yeah so I don't know if it prepared
me so much but uh yeah getting to step
into this role and kind of be able to
fill those Harvey Keitel shoes from the
original friend guys was daunting and
terrifying and wonderful all at the same
time yeah yeah
no for sure you do a great job and
definitely fill those shoes perfectly
and then uh Zuri what I love about Tasha
is she's this brain whiz in the show so
are you at that same level of Tasha and
if you're not is it strange coming back
down from that tapping out of that
um I am not no
Tasha knows way more than me
um but it was really cool to uh have her
brain for a few months filming this um
Series so amazing I had to Google a lot
lots of YouTube University moments
um looking up this and that and like
what does this word mean what really is
crypto you know
um but I know a lot more now so I will
say that she helped me um grow and
expand in in that realm for sure yeah I
think that's a really good answer and
it's cool because I feel like the
audience learns a lot from her character
as well which is really cool
um and then Lyndon was it surreal for
you getting cast in a Disney project did
you grow up a Disney fan I'm from
Florida of course like yeah King yes I'm
a huge huge Disney fan
um I've always wanted to be in the
Disney family so this is like an actual
dream come true to me um to get a job
where they let you go to Disneyland like
I can die happy
um yeah no this has been really really
surreal for me yeah no that's great it's
been awesome to talk to you guys so
everybody watch jury and Lyndon crush it
in National Treasure edge of history on
Disney plus now thank you guys so much
for joining me and I hope to talk to you
in the future one day